yeah thanks actually the uh two intraday
lectures very interesting i'll keep to
the spirit of them uh in the sense of
introducing things from first principles
in topic modeling from first principles
means where i was six months ago which i
i mean i didn't know much topic morning
at all also i'll try to make it
self-contained but i'm going to start
with um something which is a little more
uh
in a sense basic or self-contained for
the first bit and then go on to topic
modeling so
here's a simple setting uh i want us to
think about this because it's going to
illustrate uh sort of the big thing that
we are doing which is really a small
thing which is thresholding so the
setting is this you have a matrix a
which is n by n there's a subset of k
elements call it s
and
the picture looks like they're in all
the entries are independent random
variables but i've written out the
picture here and i'll say that in um
symbols there uh
for
this is uh this is s cross s this is a k
by k sub matrix
right on that sub matrix the random
variables the entries are high mu is
positive entries are high so
they are at least mu with probability at
least half think of that as the signal
so
s and mu whatever that that that stuff
is think of that as a signal
in the rest of the matrix
the entries are normal zero sigma
squared think of sigma as the noise
and that is a signal right the idea is
of course you want to figure out the
signal from the noise and you're not
told much except you're given the matrix
a
and here we might as well assume in this
toy setup that we are given also mu and
sigma we don't have to be given them and
the big thing is to find s
okay s is your signal part and those of
you who are familiar with the planted
clique problem you'll recognize this
sort of
planted league as a version of that if
you will where you put ones there and
plus or minus once here with equal
probability right
but they're all independent random views
how would we do that
um
so let's call it it obvious okay so
sorry let me go back if mu is much much
larger than sigma you can convince
yourself it's very easy to tell
if mu is much larger than sigma let's
say root log and larger there'll be
telltale signs of the big entries the
small entries the tail is so small they
wouldn't encroach on the big domain
right
again let's not work out the details but
if mu is very big compared to sigma your
home let's call this the signal to noise
ratio as it increases your life becomes
easier
in the planted clique problem uh if you
will mu and sigma are one so signal is
noise ratio is one uh and we know that
we can do the planted clique problem at
least if the signal-to-noise ratio there
is root n over k
at least
that's just the same saying 1 is greater
than over k or k is greater than root n
i've just written it in a devious way
then we can find s
and now we actually know recently that
we cannot beat this lower bound
uh in
with statistical learning algorithms i
won't define what statistical learning
algorithms are the one thesis is that
almost every algorithm we know is a
statistical learning algorithm and such
algorithms cannot beat this cannot do
planetary
so
here's a
here's what i'm going to do not for the
planted clique for the muon sigma
i'm going to introduce
i call it a brave new step half ingest
of course neither brave nor new you just
threshold entries of a at mu
so you make them one if it's greater
than mu make them zero if it's less than
mu this is a
rather trivial and simple statement
we'll see that it buys us something so
what happened now the entries in the k
by k part
or
an expected value at least half because
with at least half probability you are
greater than mu the entries in this part
it's normal sigma normal with uh
mean zero sigma squared right so the
probability that they'll exceed mu is
just this gaussian tail bound it's not
accurate i have a few other terms but
it's at most this much let's see
okay so what good is that
oh
now we we take we're not um
we know b we're not given e of b right
we know b so we just subtract this bit
from every entry of b so the mean is
zero and now what happens see something
simple and nice happens
in this part
it's easy to convince yourself the
spectral norm is at least k over 4. just
put the vector 1 over root case 1 over
root case
okay
by the way this example is so simple
that i running through the proof in
general i may not do that throughout
but in this part
the entries are mean zero standard
deviation whatever standard deviation
exponentially small so random matrix
theory tells you the spectral norm is
bounded by this
okay the only interesting thing about
this is is root n times an exponential
factor right and
therefore if i now did svd svd is the
way we solve planted clay quite often
now if i threshold the matrix and then
do svd
i find that i'll succeed provided
that k over 4 is greater than this and
that's just this right
what has that bought you well it's
actually bought you something
normal svd would only win if the signal
to noise ratio is root n over k and now
instead we only need an exponential in
the signal-to-noise ratio squared in
fact to be at most to be at least root n
over k right so we get a uh what seems
like a big advantage indeed it is over
uh what we can do with just svd
so
the model of this story is thresholding
even if it's simple can be quite nice
and useful
and i want to point out one more feature
of thresholding that's useful and these
are the two features
actually in fact the second one is what
we are going to use in this setup uh
more than the first one so suppose
you're a bunch of data points
by the way we will not yet move to topic
modeling in a few minutes i'll move to
topic modeling and then i'll tell you
more or less from first principles what
it is so we have a bunch of data points
in d-dimensional space there are d
features if you will
each each data point is a vector in the
dimensional space
and
let's um think of the problem
as far the data points
actually come from clusters like you you
have in a mixture model if you will
except now the clusters are soft what
that means is that data point j has a
weight wj or belonging to cluster one
and the rest of it belongs to cluster
two so maybe half half in the two
clusters or three fourths one fourth or
whatever right more generally there can
be k clusters
now here's an additional feature i want
to introduce now this makes natural
sense in this general setting but it'll
make much more sense in topic modeling
i want to say that each cluster has some
dominant features
important features for that cluster
and furthermore each data point has a
dominant cluster so the weights will not
be half off the weights will be
three-fourths one-fourths
something like that or 0.6.41 cluster
will be
significantly bigger in weight than the
other for each data point
and we'll see that these make actually
natural sense for topic modeling right
now they're just abstract things
and let's say that
the importance the dominance plays its
role this way
aij is greater than mu if feature i is a
dominant feature of the topic
which is dominant in the data point j
and otherwise it's slow since this is
high low feature just as you had in the
in in the problem i showed you with
signal noise so signal and this is noise
if you will
okay now
i want to illustrate a second feature of
thresholding now
if
if the heavy parts
can stretch from mu upwards all the way
to one
the light parts
stretch from sigma down to zero
if if the variance above mu can be much
larger than the gap between mu and sigma
right so mu might be 0.4 you might go
all the way from point four to one
whereas sigma might be point three so
the gap between point four and point
three is smaller than the variance above
mu perhaps okay then if you just use two
means you've used any of your clustering
criteria you'll fail it'll split the
high weight cluster because it's very
high spread right very high variance
to the low weight cluster so normal
clustering won't work
but low and behold thresholding will so
if i threshold at mu
i didn't say that but
if i threshold that mu
then the variance is taken care of
because everybody above mu becomes one
and the variance is zero right if i knew
mu and i thresholded it mu so
thresholding would really help in this
case when the dominant things have very
high variance which is also stand which
is also going to be natural in the case
of topic modeling
so that's all i'm going to say about
thresholding as i said it's simple idea
and that's going to buy us a lot
okay so here's dropping modeling this is
well this first is just a definition of
talking modeling but the work i'm going
to talk about is joint work with burn
solar and brittle chariot
so there are d features again i'm going
to assume only as much knowledge in
topic modeling as i had six months ago
which is almost nothing so i'll
introduce you uh introduce it from first
principles there are d features for some
of you who know it will be boring but
for there are d features which are words
in the dictionary twenty thousand thirty
thousand words a document is a d vector
uh a document says just could be the
frequency of words this would occur so
many times this would occur so many
times and so on no context right
uh but it's just a d vector for us
right and there are k topics k is much
smaller than d so 20 000 words perhaps
but 50 topics perhaps
okay we have a collection of documents
which cover 50 topic spreads
and the else topic is also d vector for
us
and the d vector just gives you the
probabilities of words in the topic
okay so documents as well as topics or
vectors d vectors and to generate a
document
you generate a run random convex
combination of topic vectors
this is soft clustering so uh each each
topic is a cluster as i'll come to a
little bit later and you generate a
random convex combination of the topic
vectors and then you generate words in
the document in iid trials
um well i didn't draw this picture but i
drew another picture which hopefully
will illustrate yeah so uh generate
words of document j and iid trials and
they are from multinomials with deals
probability so that's the convex
combination
yeah so you can imagine the picture the
topic modeling
problem which uh i i'm i'm it's a
standard problem but i'm putting a twist
on it that is worth paying attention
given only this matrix a
which is set of documents did i say what
a was
i didn't say that sorry excuse me a is a
matrix consisting of columns which are
documents i give you a bunch of
documents generated this way
okay and i want to find an approximation
to the k topic vectors
okay and i want the approximation to be
good in l1 error l1 error is natural for
probability of vectors right
but the other thing about l1 error
that's nice to remember is
i have 20 000 long vector right if every
entry is 1 over twenty thousand it can
be it's a probability vector
if you allow l2 error then i can just
return zero as a vector because the
squaring takes care of it so l one
doesn't have that property so it's a bit
more difficult
uh it's generally np hard
various versions restrictions are all
np-hard
but if this is not familiar i really
want to just make the point it's just
soft clustering
topic vectors are cluster centers
each data point each document
belongs to a weighted combination of
clusters
so it's generated from a distribution
which in this case multinomial doesn't
have to be with expectation equals the
weighted combination of the cluster
centers
now
again i'm going to show you a picture in
the next slide maybe this will that will
make it clear so even if we manage to
solve the clustering problem somehow
it's not really what the clustering
problem is there aren't well defined
clusters it's just soft clustering that
we have right even if you decide solve
it it's not clear cluster centers won't
be
document vectors or topic vectors sorry
so that's the distinction from learning
mixtures which is hard clustering so
this picture i hope this slide will
spend some time on it will illustrate a
lot of what i said
so
ignore that for a minute the muse or
topic vectors in this case are three
topics they are the corners of the
simplex
okay
to access each x corresponds to one
document
to generate a document
i generate a convex combination of the
corners or some somebody inside the
triangle right the red points the red
crosses each correspond to one document
they are inside the triangle but i don't
give you the right crosses life would be
very simple if i gave you the red
crosses right what i'll only give you is
the circles
uh they should all be black don't worry
about the color of the circle
the circles or words in the document so
each circle corresponds to one word in
the document
which is generated with expectation
equal to the cross right
but we are not given the crosses so some
of these words can be outside the
triangle remember because the the the
right things are inside the triangle the
weighted combinations of the topic
vectors but the circles words which are
generated with mean equals x need not be
inside the triangle they can be outside
the triangle
okay
now uh so
given what we are given is these circles
then
no crosses circles and we have to find
the muse the corners
clearly as you can see from this picture
it would really help us to find what are
called nearly pure documents a pure
document is on only one topic so if i
have a cross sitting at a corner that'd
be really pure document that's a that's
a document just on sports or just on
politics and so on and so forth right
i'm not given those but um if i could
find the crosses at least close to the
corners every corner has a cross close
to it if i could isolate those then i
can hope that that's a good
approximation to this
even that is not true because this is a
convex combination so there's a bunch of
those things but at least i can hope
that so the aim of this the first part
of the talk or much of the talk is to
find these points near the corners the
right crosses
um
let me
do a little study this is a huge topic
with a lot of nice literature but let me
just do a survey of things a few things
that are very relevant to this talk
um early on under assuming pure topics
that's assuming that each document is
purely on one topic
okay so the crosses are right in the
corners
but not the circles circles may not be
in the corners right so then i'm
assuming making another assumption about
primary words that's one minus epsilon
of the words or primary
you can think of words primary words as
sort of dominant features right
svd solves this problem that was shown
early on by papadumity raghav and tamaki
and venpala
then the long-standing question was can
sv do perhaps svd cannot do non-pure
topics non-pure means the crosses are
not at the corners they are anywhere in
the triangle
in a way
well i should say the most popular
non-fear model which is really used
widely is blinding in jordan's model
called latent dirichlet allocation which
i won't spell out
but here non it's not pure multiple
topics are allowed topic weights
are essentially uncorrelated and there
are various
more difficult models for instance blind
life at your own the trouble is in this
model computation is difficult the model
fitting problem is probably npr right so
however uh in a very nice paper anakumar
foster shoe cockadelu in a sense
answered this by showing perhaps not svd
but if you use tensors which are higher
order correlations you can view svds
second order then at least to l2 error
you can learn you can find you can solve
the problem
in the lda model
uh then there's another uh paper of
aroraga and mohitra
who sort of um
made some other assumptions you have to
make assumptions because these are empty
hard
assume that there are what are called
anchor words
and some other parameters
and anchor word is the following they
assume that each topic is one word
occurring only in the topic and occurs
with very high frequency so
it's the word is a tell-tale sign of
that topic so perhaps for baseball as a
topic the word run is an anchor word
then you'll assume that it occurs only
in the topic which is a little strong
but it's possible but you also have to
assume that it occurs with frequency
let's say point zero two so every 50th
word is that particular word
and then they were able to give actually
a probable algorithm at the end of it
now the error unfortunately is still l1
error per word so for topic vector the
error is quite high but it's the first
probable algorithm and very very good
experimental result
uh now that leads into our talk our aim
here is first to spend some since this
is theory to practice it's not all
theory but first
intuitive and empirically justified
assumptions we'll have assumptions that
we verify and then we'll give a natural
algorithm i won't tell you the proof the
algorithm is natural and simple the
proof is actually quite uh quite a bit
of work but i'll indicate what goes
words or on you uh yes i'll tell you all
that i'll tell you the essentials right
no i will tell you the essentials yeah
good i mean yeah
sanity check okay intuitive to topic
modeling not numerical parameters like
others
other things have to assume sometimes
numerical parameters okay so here are uh
so i won't use primary words i'm going
to use instead this assumption which is
a little bit different catchword think
of this as dominant features so the
assumption here is each topic has a set
of words not one word but a set of words
each of which occurs more frequently in
the topic than others so we're not
saying that it doesn't occur at all in
the other ones but more frequently and
together they have high frequency so it
doesn't have to be that one word occurs
every 20th time in the document but a
combination of words right so that is
catchwords
dominant features in other words
dominant topics each document has one
topic which is dominant has a weight
which is greater than a certain alpha
and every other weight is at least is at
most of beta which is less than alpha
okay bound on the number of catch words
allowed
uh no we don't need a boundary it can be
enormous but they're disjoint sets of
catchwords
and their total frequency must be high
though
okay so a dominant topic this seems a
bit strong uh that each document has a
dominant topic i'll show you empirical
results that say many documents do
majority do
an open problem is to relax the each
there or throw it out or say many
nearly pure documents we also assume
that each topic has a small fraction of
documents which are one minus delta p so
there are a small fraction near the
corners of the simplex right
we assume that
and again if you find those you're done
and the fourth assumption we call no
local min
uh that is for every word you plot
the number of occurrences number of
documents in which the word occurs
versus the number of occurrences
and that has no local min that curve
doesn't come down and stay down
and the justification for this is these
plots
often tend to be zif's law which is
power law but power law doesn't have a
local min it declines but for catchwords
it's not going to decline in the
beginning it's going to increase and
then go down but it's still unimodal and
it applies in these two cases in fact
empirically we observe that these are
the two things that happen
now well i don't think you need to
remember all these four but hopefully
you got the gist of it the first one
says dominant features second one says
dominant topics
dominant clusters in other words okay
the third one says points near the
simplex corners the fourth one is
perhaps a little technical but it's
based on these
two possibilities how does it relate to
the aurora
moisture model okay so their assumption
of anchor words is stronger than quechua
it's much stronger than catchwords they
don't assume dominant topics and they
don't assume this
they don't assume this but their
dependence on
various numerical parameters are there
plus the error is not l1 so i think the
crucial thing is the error is not l1 so
if you don't have the arrow one you can
throw out small words
but we observed empirically that there
are
small words occupy a constant fraction
of the entire document so there are
words that only occur five times in the
document right you can't throw them all
out if you can then then you get more
freedom
but we don't talk about this
so the algorithm will be described
i'm going to describe the steps of the
algorithm in one slide uh for this talk
s is the number of documents this sample
right because it's being generated for
this talk we assume the probability that
each topic is 1 over k
it's not
assumed in general so threshold step
much like in the signal to noise problem
and the other one i'm going to do a
threshold but here nobody gives me mu i
have to find the special furthermore the
threshold is going to be different for
different words because word frequencies
are different for different words so uh
for each word i
the threshold is going to be the first
gap
as you come from about
you take the maximum zeta so that aij
greater than zeta
for
1 over 2k fraction of the js that's
meant to be half of this so you've
captured an entire dominant topic
sorry half of a half of a dominant topic
but then you look for a gap
that is at zeta itself there aren't too
many epsilon small
so
you've covered at least half the topic
and then you go until you find the first
gap
and the proof
i won't tell you the proof but we can
prove that you cut off the entire topic
exactly more or less exactly
okay and then you use svd on the
threshold matrix so very crucial just
like the signals noise
problem you don't apply svd on the data
matrix
you apply it on a thresholded matrix
and that gives you centers for a k-means
run
then you do k means clustering
and at the end of this we we prove again
i won't prove here but it can be proved
that this identifies the dominant topic
so for almost all documents i've got
correctly what the dominant topic is
again i'll show you a picture with the
triangle in a minute
we're not done yet
that then we identify catchwords for
each topic which are the set of high
frequency words in each cluster
and this we would like to prove that
that is a set of catchwords once you've
identified catchwords you finally get to
your aim of identifying things near the
corners pure documents those would be
the set of documents with the highest
total number of occurrences of
catchwords okay we'll show that they are
nearly pure documents and therefore
their average
will be close to the topic vector
because they are the ones near the
corners
okay here is a picture
uh what the svd and k means and all that
does is just identifies dominant topics
what does that mean so i've drawn only
the region where the the top dot top
topic is dominant
things closest to that if you will i
would have identified all the circles in
this in this region
and also all the circles in this region
all circles the circumstances
that's what the clustering will do
see i
went to in how many minutes was the talk
overall anyway
no you can tell me one of the two when
does it end
30 minutes okay yeah it's good
okay so i think we're fine
um
so uh this is what i've accomplished in
uh
in
all the way up to here
right
the clustering
uh not the soft cluster i mean these
these things are really belong quite a
bit to this cluster too right but we've
identified the dominant topic
so are we done
now
i claim we are far from done because if
i took the average of all the circles in
this region
i would not get anything like the corner
which is what i'm aiming to get i get
somebody in the middle right that's of
no use
so that's of course very different from
heart clustering
right in heart clustering there'll be
spew around that but that's not
happening
there'll be a few points outside as well
so
before now i'm going to backtrack and
tell you a few things about the proof so
thresholding um what does it accomplish
we saw what it accomplishes in the sort
of signal to noise setup let's see what
it accomplishes here we'll prove that
it turns out that thresholding we can
use the no local min assumption and that
implies thresholding does not split any
dominant topic in the middle
so
it doesn't split any of these clusters
in the middle thresholding would not be
very nice if it did okay
so
threshold making is a block matrix for
catchwords
for non-catch words
it still doesn't split the topic but
they can be high on several topics
okay yeah so
maybe
it's done this this is nice because you
have a board as well as so you don't
have to repair your pictures in the
beginning
so this is topic one
topic two topic three topic four these
are documents dominant in that these are
catchwords for topic one
two
three
four and there are a lot of non-catch
words
and this is very important because
empirically one observes that
quite a lot of words for small
small number of occurrences so what we
if the thresholding is ideally correct
this would all be one this would be a
diagonal matrix
and these words uh
would be ones on perhaps several topics
and zeros and others
that's all
if the picture is ideal of course it
won't be right there will be a lot of us
um by the way in the paper we don't set
things about the threshold to one they
they are weighted as well but right now
we just pretend it's one
there is only one catchword topic no
many catchwords
so this is i'm sorry sorry i drew it i i
this is really a number of words sorry
okay so there are many rules in there
many of all ones if it's ideal
so if it was ideal then you'd be more or
less done you would think i mean somehow
you should be but it's it's not going to
be that's problem
by the way on the previous you showed
this picture with the three simplex and
then you said things are not clustered
but they seem like just a kind of very
low dimensional
this is like a this is a low dimensional
phenomenon right
you you're using the fact that uh no
it's still we are still living in d
dimensions significantly so because i
mean in your picture the fact that the
simplex constraint forces you know makes
it so that these things oh i see it's a
k dimensional simplex sitting in d space
so
we are still up there in these spaces we
have not come to the k space
just the fact that he was this in the
picture it was a low dimensional simplex
you know made it seem as though these
topics are very far from the you know
from their dominant these documents are
very far from their dominant topic but
this this was uh oh you have a good
point so
the points are a little more pushed
towards the corners yes
but you know what is so we only assume
that the dominant topics are 8.4 or 0.3
or something the 0.7 of the weight comes
from the other topics
but hey the floor is open also to
non-organizers if you have questions
so um
okay so
we have that
um
so that's after thresholding we already
have something like that right but of
course the picture is fuzzy so you have
to use clustering to do the problem do
the job right
now an important point in clustering is
which i said before
and thresholding helps this but let's do
a picture so we might have a bunch of
clusters
there are two parameters of interest one
is the inter inside cluster spread
and the other one is the spread between
these two so this is a this is b
so what we need
for clustering intuitively is a must be
bigger than b right
otherwise you'll confuse clusters
so let's see if that's true so we need
um inter cluster separation to be
greater than intra cluster spread
variance inside the cluster
now catchwords provide sufficient
intercluster separation so uh
catchwords so the this this one zero and
zero one says these two clusters are
very very far apart okay sufficiently
far apart
so that satisfies one side of the
inequality that inter cluster separation
is large how about intra cluster spread
variance inside a cluster
so inside cluster variance
uh it turns out can be bounded but this
needs machinery we have to use machinery
from random matrix theory and there's
one little uh nice thing nowadays is
that
in random activity originally right we
knew things where all entries are iid
independent or independent at least now
we know of course substantially equally
good results almost where only the rows
or only only the columns are independent
so the documents are independent vectors
it's not true that words inside
documents are independent right if a
word occurs in a document it's less
likely that some other word will occur
so there's a lot of dependence there but
that's fine random matrix theory by now
is just as good for that as as it was
for independent entry so we can use that
now we also crucially use something else
so
we use a result
that i had a few years back
which says the following if inter
cluster separation
this a
much greater than b
you don't need that you only need that
inter cluster separation is much greater
than inside cluster
directional standard deviation that
means the standard deviation in one
direction and that actually is
of general importance so maybe i should
draw that picture
to tell you why that's important why
that's not trivial so if i had two
gaussians
of the same variance in d dimensions
right
let's call it the
separated the center separated by delta
we all know that as long as delta is now
uh this is just two gaussians here
a few standard deviations of a
this is a result in general of impala
and one for two gaussians it's
completely trivial that
sort of intuitively the mnemonic is if
the inter center separation is at least
a few standard deviations where the few
does not depend on the ambient dimension
d right d can be very large
then you can separate them
you can cluster and separate them right
and
this is a generalization of that you
only have to take what is it saying you
only have to take the standard deviation
sigma in one direction
the overall spread of the cluster is
root d sigma right because there are d
d dimensions
so you cannot require that the centers
be apart by root t sigma that doesn't
happen in reality it's sufficient that
they be apart by one sigma or a constant
number of sigmas okay so that's true in
full generality and that's that's a
result from that and using that then you
can separate that there's no dependence
on k
there's a dependence on k yeah
uh well i don't know what is it central
what's the best dependency to the one
fourth okay the one foot okay
good now i can ask the audience
questions as well yeah scale the one
fourth is the best separation but yeah
you've chosen based on the couch words i
mean if you have a certain number of
catch words you know how well the final
clusters are
so in
the setup so far i'm assuming k is given
to you by god right i mean just you have
it's core
it's a truth yeah it's a tool but
you you can play around with different
cases we haven't i haven't you know i'm
not going to talk about that but yes
indeed that's an issue
how to choose cave you're not given
uh okay it doesn't matter well this is
the picture i i thought i had a picture
okay i am now going to the experimental
slides but i had a oh no i already
showed you the two pictures i had okay
okay good so um
that's the
so far the theory part
a little on the experiments
nice to make it full right
don't all use windows somehow how do you
do how do you make this
top left
red green
green okay good
okay so uh so i'm not an expert on the
experiments but we didn't do them my
quarters did
ml apple
apple
where is that
that's where the windows button should
be
but it's oh it says command right now
okay now
windows button it should be it's not
it's a function button there okay
not functional
menu
under view
oh great thank you
thanks a lot by the way you can not only
ask questions but change the slides as
well it's useful
so we did um
i don't know there were four
four uh corporate documents you know
they had so many documents also
okay so this is checking the assumptions
so one of the things we did i'll show
you only a couple of these uh i'm not
going to show you all the other stuff
but um
the number so why did we made these
assumptions are they valid right so the
fraction of documents satisfying the
dominant topic assumption
alpha is saying that the topic weight
should be at least 0.4 the dominant
topic
if you want the point the dominant topic
to 0.8 at least that's of course
requiring a lot there aren't so many at
0.4 there are quite a few
i should backtrack one step i should
tell you that
even in lda we know and it was folklore
and now we have a simple proof that the
prior has puts a lot of weight on one
topic if what's called a concentration
parameter is low and in fact this d but
these are empirically observed so we
take the corpus
and then we look for after we fit
the model look for whether dominant
topics exist they exist in this
percentages documents with point four as
i said it'll be nice just i think the
thing will work if the assumption is
changed to only a constant fraction of
the documents of dominant topics we
don't have that yet we assume everyone
now
catches assumption rho is
rho is uh
the gap that is uh you are 1.1
times more likely to be
the word is more likely to occur 1.1
times by a factor 1.1 in the dominant
topic than other topics and then you
find that almost every topic has
catchwords
okay
and
this is the total frequency of
catchwords and the topic is point zero
five and so on so this says every
twentieth word is a catchword this says
every about ninth word is a catchword
and so on
do yeah know here do you need to use
many catchwords in order to sort of yeah
i think uh uh 20-ish number of
catchwords is 20. yeah i mean i don't
answer all the experimental questions
for that and remember yeah it's about
20.
i guess did you compare it to see if the
anchor word assumption holds or not on
these corpora so
many topics don't have anchor words okay
well see so
i have to say to the cat so if you want
a word that occurs in the topic mostly
and not so much in other topics they do
exist
but if you wanted to have a reasonably
high frequency like point zero five then
it's a problem
if they're very low frequency the
theoretical bounds they give or very
high so you know
so
so you don't get anchor words if you
assume let's say 0.05 frequencies
necessary
ah this is about how these things were
done right so
the catch words how do they look like do
you i mean you can interpret them well
yeah actually they they i didn't have
that slide or may have it somewhere but
they do turn out they seem to be nice
words i mean so yeah so in machine
learning i mean we have a list of words
that came up but they seem to be decent
words and if you compare it with other
methods how are those the
interpretations
like
coherence or yeah yeah so i have
some of these more interesting nouns
like perplexity and coherence yeah at
the end i i don't know what they are but
they're coming up in the pictures of
them all right um but they seem to be
nice words in general
uh
so
how the methodology
uh this is similar to are moitra that is
we generate a semi-synthetic corpus from
the lda model first so first you take a
real corpus then you train an lda model
on that using standard methods okay that
gives you a top that gives you topic
vectors and then you generate
semi-synthetically from those topic
vectors that's what we did
um
so this is a
the procedure to
do this oh and we used
what you could say is a low-ish
dirichlet hyperparameter if you're
familiar with that doesn't matter
um
and
dominant topic assumption is not assumed
to be satisfied right so
we for the theory we made all these
assumptions we did not assume
uh for the corpora we got right they
don't have to satisfy the assumptions
but still you get decent results now
decent means this
um
so the l1 reconstruction error on
various semi-synthetic size so
um
this i think oh this is our algorithm
click means i think it's better so these
two are our other again
algorithms due to them i think this is
better their their kl algorithm is
generally better than the l2
think kl is it's not really kl it's but
kl is used as a measure for how much the
algorithm has converged both are similar
in both this cases identifying
convergence
only the conversion is different
so we do do worse on
the 20 news group by a little bit but
the others we seem to do better that's
that's the reading okay so i should say
the l1 error can go up to two right
because the two probability vectors so
generally you get these kinds of l one
errors um
you know that's uh
i don't know whether
those numbers are great or anything but
you get them at least um
they seem to be good actually consider
okay this is that
question you asked
perplexity uh where is is that what this
is no this is also i'm sorry this is
so this is showing that in fact what
happens with our algorithm and we were
puzzled for a while on this that in fact
on most topics
uh we seem to have very low l1 error
even lower than what's reported but we
do get outliers these are very high l1
errors so this x axis is l1 error right
uh 1.2 for instance right on one topic
greater than one is possible because
there are two probability vectors you
can go up to two but that's there are
two topics which are very bad the rest
seem to be good so this is an
illustration that that happens
ah this is your perplexity and
this somebody in the audience will know
better the definition of these things
perplexity is some
estimate of the posterior probability in
lda which is difficult to conclude
exactly it's e to the minus likelihood
e to the minus likelihood right but an
approximation to that because
you can't do the exact thing
well that's introduced by blinding and
jordan that's used quite often for all
of these things
then let's see if i have any more
that's all i have okay this
i think i'm done so just in time you can
ask questions
questions
like that's something like
usually when we
run our game in practice like the choice
of k is a is a huge problem
now with all the theoretical assumptions
does it offer a way to you know guide
the choice okay or constrain that
yeah so that's a very good point so i
think it we haven't done this yet and i
haven't proved anything but i would
suspect if you try a few case
the right k will stand out quite a bit
so
i'm going out on a limb on this i have
neither theory nor experiment back but i
think that that would be true
but you need a good question to see how
you can get at the right kid
so it seems one of the assumptions is
the corner of the simplex has a lot
higher probability of being hit i guess
i've seen data where say the two the 1d
sub spaces are high or the 2d subspaces
and like you're going to have sports and
within sports you could have you know
baseball and soccer or whatever right
so have you considered any kind of
hierarchical stuff you mean or something
like well just that in the case of by
you know like a triangle that well there
wasn't a lot of points in the corner but
there was a lot of points on the edges
oh i see um
it's not okay so
there is a vague intuitive argument that
in fact you must assume that there are
points in the corners for
identifiability so you cannot get you
cannot hope to get the exact corners
with l1 error unless you have
sufficiently many documents around there
in some sense
because you know so if you you so the
what is the problem the overall problem
is just to find a simple affiliate and
closes all your data points more or less
right but i could have found a very
large simplex that's not useful
i must find in a way the smallest
simplex that encloses your data points
then smallest what does it mean volume
or and so on so forth right
but if you assume enough points any
other corners you can say you must find
a simplex
which consists corners or more or less
more or less data points you have
and still enclose most of the data
points so that pins down identifiability
so you need something like that
i don't know how to do it if you had
only points near the near the edges
where you have to find smallish simplex
containing all of them
i thought he was asking a different
question where instead of the topics
being single points in space the topics
are let's say line segments
and your space is the convex hull of
these can you then identify the line
segments because now they correspond to
um but
is that what you're asking something
like that yeah
no i don't know i mean but in topic
modeling usually you seem to assume that
topics are single vectors but yes i mean
it's fair enough that you could do try
that i don't know
no no idea
but if you do not want l1 error like the
comment you made about like you need
points so listen near the corners right
if you do not
ask for l1 error then you can
that's a that's a good that's true if
you don't ask for l1 error you can live
with without points near the corners so
if you're not l2 error right
then you can ignore small coordinates
and then you don't need points near the
corners you can do it without
so maybe that that's true so maybe l2
error you can do
uh it seems like the definition of core
words was implicit and the four words
get assigned to topic for something
really close to one so if you relax that
assumption
then what happens to your ability to
identify topics in other words
you know a priority that the question
and core words are assigned to
california's epsilon to certain topics
well you mean but no we don't assume one
mindset but in the topic vector chord
words i mean catchwords might have very
low frequency
but
they should have even lower frequency in
the less dominant topics that's all they
assume
so the frequency of a single word in a
topic might be 0.001 it might still be a
catch word because it's only 0.0005 in
the other topics
right
but the list of catches together should
have high enough frequency and that
seems realistic in a sense we do see
that there are catchers like that can
you decide you have to know which topic
no we don't have to know anything like
that in the beginning so we can find we
find all that
we find the catchwords
for each topic
questions
well i have a good
question so have you actually compared
to lda itself not to the model but the
very car
okay so that's a good question here is
actually a fundamental question how do
you compare to lda what is a measure
of comparison perplexity is a possible
measure
but it's not a precise measure
okay uh lda i mean so you can say
there's a real corpus
i find topic vectors using lda but we
don't know that they are the right topic
vectors right
i mean the only thing we would know if
you could compute the posterior
accurately which is which is there but i
don't think we know how to compute the
posterior well enough well one thing you
could try you can generate something
from lda model and then try to recover
it back that of course would be an
unfair advantage to that no that's what
we do i mean lda model so if you don't i
think you don't compare maybe i'm
mistaking do you actually compare to lda
the perplexity is comparing directly
it's like the e to the minus posterior
but they are bound on mostly because
it's a relaxation of the posterior which
you can compute
well
any other questions